today marks one month since russia
began its carnage in ukraine the brutal
invasion of ukraine
and uh we held a nato summit the very
next day
at that time my overwhelming objective
was one in that summit was to have
absolute unity on three key important
issues among our nato and european
allies
first was
to support ukraine
with military and humanitarian
assistance
second was
to impose the most significant the most
significant sanctions economic sanction
regime ever in order to [ __ ] putin's
economy and punish him for his actions
third was to fortify the eastern flank
of our nato allies who were obviously
very very concerned and somewhat
worried what would happen
we accomplished all three of these that
today were determined to sustain those
efforts
and to build on them
the united states has committed to
provide over two billion dollars in
military equipment ukraine since i
became president
and i air systems anti-armor systems
ammunition
and our weapons are flowing into ukraine
as i speak
and today i'm announcing the united
states and prepared to commit
more than one billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance to help get
relief to millions of ukrainians
affected by the war in ukraine
many ukrainian refugees will uh will
wish to stay in europe closer to their
homes
but we also will welcome 100 000
ukrainians united states with a focus on
reuniting families
and we will invest 320 million dollars
to bolster democratic resilience and
defend human rights in ukraine in
neighboring countries
we're also coordinating
with the g7 and the european union on
food security as well as energy security
i'll have more to say about that
tomorrow
we're also announcing new sanctions
of more than 400 individuals and
entities aligned
with in alignment with the european
union
more than 300 members of the douma
oligarchs and russian defense companies
that fuel the russian war machine
in addition to the 100 000 u.s forces
now stationed in europe to defend nato
territory
nato established as you already know
four new battle groups from romania
hungary bulgaria and slovakia to
reinforce the eastern front
putin was banking on nato being split
my early conversations in december and
early january was clear to me he didn't
think we could sustain this cohesion
nato has never never been more united
than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine sir
deterrence didn't work
what makes you think vladimir putin will
alter course based on the action you've
taken today let's get something straight
you remember if you covered me from the
very beginning i did not say that in
fact the sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter
the maintenance of sanctions
the maintenance of sanctions the
increasing the pain and the
demonstration why i asked for this nato
meeting today is to be sure that after a
month we will sustain what we're doing
not just next month the following month
but for the remainder of this entire
year that's what we'll stop doing you
believe the option today will have an
impact on making russian change course
in ukraine that's not what i said
you're playing a game with me i know the
answer is no
i think what happens is we have to
demonstrate the purpose the single most
important thing is for us to stay
unified
and the world continue to focus on what
a brute this guy is and all the innocent
people's lives are being lost and ruined
and what's going on
that's the important thing but look if
you're putin
and you think that the
europe is going to crack
in a month or six weeks or two months
why not
they can take anything for another month
but we have to demonstrate the reason i
ask for the meeting we have to stay
fully totally thoroughly united thank
you